hello we're glad you've joined us for
this live webinar easy automation
solutions better results I am Judy
Oracle levers and I'll be moderating
this session today is educational web
seminar is presented by lab roots the
leading scientific social networking
website and provider of virtual events
and webinars advancing science at the
collaboration and learning it's brought
to you by Desmond culture life sciences
this webinar is actually the first
presentation in a three-part series on
laboratory automation solutions for
smaller labs and those less familiar
with automation who are interested in
standardizing workflows and saving costs
to improve efficiency and results this
year of beckman coulter life sciences is
celebrating 30 years in automation as
they continue to provide liquid handling
solutions to help accelerate reliable
results that drive scientific discovery
Beckman offers a full range of flexible
and scalable biomech automated
workstations and integrated systems to
automate genomic cellular protein and
other work or flows in a wide variety of
research areas including agriculture
cancer and infectious diseases
cardiovascular forensics and
neurodegenerative disorders for genomic
applications biomech automated
workstations are complemented by growing
portfolio of nucleic acid extraction and
purification kits those on the company's
patented solid-phase reversible
immobilization SPR I magnetic bead
technology let's get started this
webinar has been approved for continuing
educational credits please click on the
CD button autumn left corner and follow
the process to receive your credits you
can pose questions to the speakers
during the presentation while they're
fresh in your mind to do so simply type
them into the Q&A box which will open
when you click the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window questions will be answered after
the presentation to enlarge the slide
window click on the screen icon in the
lower right hand corner of the slide
window if you experience technical
problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
button found at the top right of the
present
asian window or report your problem by
clicking on green Q&A button at lower
left I now present today's speakers
David Horvath MS and Zack Smith ms or
both senior applications scientists for
beckman coulter life sciences david
automates propriety and third-party next
generation sequencing chemistry he has
Masters of Science in medical and
regular genetics from the Indiana
University School of Medicine David's
career experiences span a broad range of
life science fields including forensic
DNA analysis medical diagnostics and
agricultural biotech Jack automates
propriety and third-party
next-generation sequencing tips he has
masters in environmental science from
Indiana University previously exact
worked at the University Center for
genomics and bioinformatics is a project
scientist David will now begin this
presentation thank you thank you to all
of our attendees by Demi with us this
morning or I guess evening depending on
where you're at as Duty mentioned this
is part one of the three-part webinar
series and so they will be talking about
introducing your customers to automating
NGS workflows will continue in June with
the second part of DNA and RNA
sequencing sample prep and then go into
a little more detail on specific method
ranging from simple to complex the third
part of the series is entitled mission
possible on meeting NGS sample prep for
challenging samples and nisha
application so we'll be discussing some
of the applications that are becoming
available for niche markets and how we
address challenges manual processing for
those chemistry's
okay so again we want to talk about what
a typical end she has work fluids and
typicals and quotes for a reason because
there really isn't a typical NGS
workflow in general though it followed
this workflow that we have on the slide
you start with cdna synthesis for RNA
seek applications and then continuing
from there you have your traditional
library construction steps which will
include and repair a tailing ligation of
the adapters and subsequent cleanups
after each of those steps pcr richmond
is optional for certain workflows and
depending on the workboat target capture
is also an optional part of an NGS
workflow following the traditional
library prep construction you will
continue on to do library QC
quantitation and sequencing preparation
and the actual sequencing run itself so
although most NGS workflows follow this
consistent path the specific workflow
can vary greatly for each application
they can range from single day short and
simple protocols to multi-day highly
complex protocols even though the
workflows can vary greatly they all
shared common elements such as reagent
and vine transfers sample transfers
fee-based sample cleanup and or site
selection as well as the recycling and
incubation reactions so we focused on
the modularity of those common elements
and optimize those and then construct
them in different ways to basically
assemble the workflows for each
individual application here we have some
workflow examples of a simple NGS
workflow for the rubicon genomics
through plex plasma speed chemistry the
protocol takes approximately three and a
half hours to complete it's performed in
a single plate for all the reactions
and there's a limited number of start
and stop points so it's relatively
simple manual process and also a
relatively simple application on the
automation as well the first column here
at Logan are busy on the detail that's
basically your library construction and
the second column is an optional cleanup
following your library construction the
next example get into more I guess a
typical workflow as far as complexity is
concerned and this example is for the
alumina to seek nano DNA chemistry it's
approximately a one-day protocol it
involves multiple reactions and clean up
plates and has multiple start start and
stop points to continue on to a
difficult or highly complex method
example this is an example of the
alumina true Sikh RNA access method
which is approximately a three-day
protocol and includes target capture
following library construction or
adapter ligation and it has an
increasingly larger number of labrum
consumables due to the overall length of
the process and it's highly complex with
numerous start and stop points so again
all these workflows follow a series of
reaction setups incubations clean ups
etc it's just the length of the
application and the complexity of how
those steps are pieced together to
create the overall workflow so if you're
already processing if you're already
processing NGS samples by hand you know
the challenges of the NGS workflow so
some of those challenges are significant
amount of manual pipetting steps so with
the significant amount of pipetting you
have higher variability especially with
clean up such as adapter cleanups or
your final sample
often it requires skilled pipetting so
what I mean by that is transferring a
viscous liquid in well tip mixing or
preventing magnetic be carryover while
transferring supernatant off of a play
manual pipetting steps can also
contribute to user fatigue and injury
manual processing is highly error-prone
some examples would be sample and or
index transfer mix-ups sample
normalization errors master mix recipe
calculation errors and pipette volume
setting errors so basically saying if I
bet to the wrong volume affecting
reaction chemistry b ratios etc that are
important for cleanup or recycle ection
in addition manual processing provides
limited throughput and reduced data
generation small labs or any lab for
that matter as always there always
limited in personnel resources how many
people you have to get the work done
whether you have a small amount of work
or a large amount of work people always
a limiting factor in how much you can
get done often there's more effort spent
on routine sample processing versus more
value adding data analysis so automation
can minimize or eliminate all of these
challenges so with that being said
beckon Coulter would like to think that
every lab we want to automate but we
hear from customers they're not ready to
automate and here are some reasons that
they give as to why they're not ready to
make that jump from manual processing to
automate processes we are too small well
automation reduces the effort of routine
processing it increases productivity
even with limited personnel resources so
to allow your your small lab with
limited number of personnel to be able
to do more work more effectively
and again be able to focus on the value
adding data analysis work versus routine
sample processing lab multiple senator
throughput is not high enough justify
automating well throughput is not the
only reason for automation automation
provides more accurate and reproducible
sample data irrespective of sample
numbers and is scalable to match a last
growing need some last field that they
shut their people more than machines so
biomech applications are demonstrated
and qualified with data to support
robust performance and I'll talk a
little bit later about how our
development process works for our
applications and the types of data that
we generate the support those claims in
the performance of the application
budget budgets are always limited
whether you're a small lab or a large
lab so automation can provide
significant savings over manual
processing through reduced labor or
overtime pay reduced rework caused by
human error and reduce consumable usage
via efficient lab we're in tipp handling
so encourage labs to look at the big
picture of how automation can fit into
their workflow and provide an overall
cost savings as compared to manual
processing and lastly we don't have the
expertise to operate and maintain
laboratory automation so by Microsoft
Word is full-featured and easy to use
which makes it the right solution for
either the modest or experienced user
okay so for the middle portion of the
presentation we're going to talk about
what beckman coulter does to develop an
application so we're going to start with
market research followed by building
collaborative partnerships scoping the
requirements and features of the
application and then begin a development
process where we develop and optimizing
that didn't test the method with real
reagents and generate
data and then produce content such as
tech notes application notes posters
webinar such as that which go through an
internal and external review process
that followed by insulation the
applications at the customer site and
then post installation support solve
over some details on to those parts of
our development process to start with we
have market research we're looking out
into the field to see what applications
are in demand and we gather that
feedback from various places whether
thats trade shows customers publications
journal articles etc to see what people
are doing in their research and we
utilize that to set a queue up to
prioritize which applications we're
going to focus on development when we
select the application is to develop we
want to build collaborative partnerships
with the chemistry vendors and key
research institutions so there are great
partnerships we work to ensure that be
the chemistry is being automated in in
the manner in which it was intended to
be run manually so working with the
chemistry defenders to ensure that the
data quality comes out automated the
same as it does manually if not better
and we partner with key research
institutions customers who are either
using this chemistry already by hand or
have an interest in automating this
chemistry in their lab and we use them
as a the real world case example for
processing these samples in a customer's
lab so we generate get it together and
ensure that through that partnership
that we have a robust and reliable
solution to go up to our broader
customer base so after those
collaborations are made the next step is
to scope out the requirements and
features for the particular applications
the goal is to develop a template method
that can be readily deploy the customers
a template method is going to be a
method that
covers the majority of options and
workflows that we expect to see on the
field but still need flexible enough to
offer configuration for user specific
needs one that gets out into the field
we focus on things such as throughput
capacity walk away time we consider
various accessories and integrated
devices that are required to perform the
various workflow steps workflow options
such as sample number save stop points
any type of manual interactions for the
cycle that might be needed all those are
considered while scoping out the method
as well as the instrument platform
selection so I'll talk about our
instrument platforms we have multiple
configurations which provide flexible
throughput and capability to handle any
NGS workflow the biomech 4000 is our
injured dr. he's been shot model it
sized just right for low to medium
throughput labs typically we develop
applications anywhere from 1 to 24
sample done on this instrument while I
can't handle greater numbers of samples
doodlee limited to that number so that
walk away capability and efficiency is
still realized on that platform it has a
pot that has interchangeable pipetting
tools so there's single tools and eight
channel pipette ahead it also has
interchangeable rivers so you can't have
the ability to move laughs we're on the
deck and not have them be fixed in one
spot the neck way out below is the is a
typical example of our NGS set up for
the bottleneck 4000 it includes an
orbital shaker static healthy a device
for keeping regions chilled the next
platform is our biomech nxp and that's
going to be our mid-sized unit it's
capable of medium to high throughput
workflows up to 96 samples it has
various pod options it's a single pod
which can be either a span 8 or a
multi-channel pod the multi-channel
options for either 96 or 384-well hadn't
but also has a capability of enhanced
multi selective tip pipetting which is a
multi-channel head that has capability
to pipette single rose single columns or
even individual Wells so it provides
some flexibility of a span system while
still providing the efficiency of a
multi-channel head there's approximately
15 exhibitions and a highly customizable
deck allowing an increasing capacity
over the biomech 4000 and again an
example of our typical NGS deck set up
below with a static pelletier in the
back left corner there's an orbital
shaker in the back middle trash chute on
the right and the two positions on the
far left are stacking positions that
increases capacity for additional tip
storage or plate storage and lastly we
move into our bottleneck FXP which is
our largest platform it's a high
throughput it's a fitting system for
Hydra quarter complex workflows up to 96
samples or more that's the stress that
the sizes or the amount of throughput
you have inside of your lab doesn't
necessarily dictate the size of the
instrument that would be right for you
if the word flow requirements boom for
your particular application required a
lot of cleanups and a lot of enzyme
transfers and having a duel bot system
regardless of throughput or total
capacity is still beneficial to your lab
so the thymic fxp can be configured with
the combination of two pod a
multi-channel 96 or 384-well head as
well as the span a pod you can have two
monthly channels a multi-channel in the
span and the option of those and the
deck is highly configurable it offers a
large of deck than an X or the bottom of
4,000 with approximately 20 dec position
the example NGS deck layout that we have
below includes it
rated T robot which is our integrated
thermal cycler on the left there's a
wash station in the back row on the left
which allows for reuse of tips after
transfers an orbital shaker and then
also static healthy a device to keep
regis chilled as well continuing on the
scoping options and things that are
considered when when developing a method
we have options for lab or selection
heating and cooling orbital shaking and
tib mixing and tip utilization sole
adverse selection could be tubes vs
plates what's the right lab work for
your application can be based on sample
number then volume the to what capacity
you need for your sample we have options
for reagent reservoirs whether it's a
full plate reservoir we have module run
doors as shown in the center picture
below which can hold different volumes
of reagents based on the amount needed
for each application the right modular
reservoir is matched to the volume to
reduce that volume there's a necessary
magnetic plate for beat separation the
example picture on the bottom left there
and then thermocycler lids might be
another lab word option that's needed
with integrated thorough cycling under
deck there's consideration for tip
mixing versus shaking corporal shaking
delivers fast efficient plate mixing it
reduces tip usage and provides uniform
results whereas tip mixing works well
for larger volumes it prevents
cross-contamination with lab weird
that's a Dornier well capacity so if you
have a well that's almost full orbital
shaking is the right option for that
particular next step so tip mixing will
be deployed for those purposes and
fitness thing can also access tubes or
lab where that are not compatible with
will death or both with an orbital
shaker deck like a 65 for aluminum tube
rack has your aluminum to rack that will
not fit on our orbital shaker heating
and cooling options pelletier are even
to use the heat and cool there's various
adapters that can be fit on to the
surface of the pelletier to accommodate
various labrador so round bottom weld
flat bottom pcr adapters etc there's
open with an open position so there is
no place feeling so considerations have
to be made for higher temperatures and
evaporation there is a slower ramping
and cooling Student Service eichler's
have and it's not all an ideal for all
applications such as high temperatures
because of evaporation issues thorough
cycling can be integrated it can be
integrated on all of our platforms by
Mike for dynamics t or F XP and the
thermal cycle is provided to operate
solution not having to interact with
your with a method for every intubation
that you need to perform and familiar
with some of the longer applications
there's multiple incubations that face
place in which would require multiple
user interventions for optic their
recycling so this allowed the instrument
to move the plate automatically to the
thermocycler and continue to method
without any user intervention the plate
ceiling would prevent evaporation and
then the few robots are compatible with
commonly used pcr lavender and we
continue to do development work to
integrate additional manufacturers their
recycling components as well so tip
selection choosing the tip size is
important depending on the type of
raising your transferring to the type of
labrador trying to access so our tips
come in various volume ranges
20 my fingers up to 1000 microliters
there's Sarah barrier or nominee your
options and we also have conducted the
non-conductive tips which are used to
live among sensing so tube axis is
important part of the selection of P
25th is shorter it has a higher volume
without the bear even twenty microliters
and this might be the right option for
shallow microtiter plate where the p50
is the longer tip some more slender and
it would work more effectively with the
default plate so that was a lab where
and bedecked layout and all the
accessories and active devices are
selected for the application we then
start looking at method workflow options
so if you're familiar with our methods
you familiar with the user interface
that we have at the start of the wrong
if you're not familiar than methods all
of our methods have a user interface and
so what user interface does is provide
all the option settings that are
relevant to the specific application
it's going to have things such as
options for on or off deck recycling
options for train mode which allows you
to quickly run through a method without
the lengthy mutations that can be used
for training or optimization and testing
laboratories it includes options for all
relevant applications specific options
that could be in this case and ask for
the Swift Biosciences method there's
sample input options and fragment size
options as well which part of the method
that you're wishing to run so in this
case the PCR free portion of the method
has been selected with various index and
after transfer options all the options
are validated for proper selection to
ensure that that correct inputs are made
by the user and will not generate errors
upon execution of the run and there's
also safe stopping points built in to
these options to allow safe standing
points matching the manufacturer's
protocol ability to safely store
at 48 points separate state stopping
points for pre and post PTR being able
to stop them that vision insurance for
your samples to a different instrument
if that happens to be the way that your
labs polling management system dictates
allows for all technique nations and
safe stop points love for recovery by
being able to perform portions of the
method or go back in the workflow to a
previous point and continue from there
and lastly other considerations that we
have in the deck for chemistry specific
issues there can be multiple issues but
some examples that we have here are
considerations for sodium hydroxide so
certain reactions are dependent on
sodium hydroxide to be prepared fresh so
we have building considerations for that
where prompts are presented to the user
at the right time of method to present
the deck with that particular reagent
for ethanol we have considerations over
evaporation and water occasions to those
to the ethanol so we want to ensure that
the dead volume is correct for ethanol
depending on the length of the run walk
away is great but if you have ethanol on
your deck for an entire data and we
definitely have to have considerations
for those types of reagents so after all
those considerations are made in scoping
is set out we begin our development and
optimization process so template methods
are written to follow the manufacturer's
protocol and then we hit the lab we have
facility here in Indianapolis with
multiple instruments and all or all of
our platforms we use live chemistry and
we're the ultimate goal is to generate
data with the kit that customers are
actually going to use so to start we do
thorough dry testing and
testing to make sure that the method
structure is found that lab wars moving
where it's supposed to be pipetting is
occurring in the well at the right depth
with us from the bottom to the top of
the plate when that all checks out we
move into light creation testing and
what that is is using ethanol or
glycerol solutions to mimic enzyme
transfers we are the manufacturer of our
be chemistry that you seeing all the NGS
kit though we have the ability to test
be dispensing an accuracy of the be
ratios in house with our with our own
chemistry so we use real chemistry when
possible during the light reagent
testing and optimization and then we go
into optimizing and calendaring
pipetting specific to each application
or specific transfer so again with with
be clean up sighs collection vol
transfers and ratios are critically same
for any type of reaction set of the
balance of the chemistry's is critical
to the optimal performance of the
application so each of our pipetting
techniques can be dialed in to very
accurate accurate volume transfers
across the range of the pipette tip so
we spend time to make sure that that set
up as accurately as possible to generate
the most robust results following the
optimization we move into our live
chemistry testing so we've we've ensured
that the method is sound are pending
optimization is up to spec and then we
actually run real kits with real
chemistry with real samples this needed
after data generated we continue to do
optimization that we sometimes don't see
until we use the actual chemistry and we
continue to fine-tune the message until
we have the results that we're looking
for so deserving those results based on
quantitative and qualitative data such
as bioanalyzer tracing qpcr data and
downstream into the sequencing data in
sequencing metrics so next part of our
process is content generation in review
and I'm going to hand off to my
colleague Zack Smith and he's going to
continue with our development process
from this point forward okay thank you
very much to thank you everyone for
sticking with us for this one it's done
a pretty good job so far I'm hoping to
pick up where he left off so content
generation and review process so that's
where we generate the technical and
application notes to demonstrate an epic
capabilities and the robustness of our
application the first thing we'll do is
we will have the chemistry vendor go
through our our data either our QC
traces from the Bob analyzer qpcr
results or our sequencing metrics and
review those and make sure that the
chemistry vendor is content with the
results as David said we have a facility
here in Indianapolis that is fully
equipped with this work we have two
sequencers in-house and aluminum I see
you in the next c500 that we can use to
generate the sequencing data we need if
we need more data we have worked on a
couple of projects that required hi-c
data we can certainly work with the
vendors or we send those out for
additional data analysis and then we
work with the bioinformatics groups
associated with the reagent vendors to
to analyze those data and interpret and
properly the data must meet acceptable
meals yields for metrics our metrics for
yield the sizing must be accurate and
the sequencing metrics such as the
percent VOR ort and nation if you're
working with an RNA method or the
percent on target for 30 percent on
target reads for a capture method must
be consistent with what the reagent
vendor is seeing in the manual prep the
other thing we look for is evidence of
cross-contamination so our
methods are working with all them plates
typically which helps speed the workflow
along because then you're not having to
see you around Taylor plates but we do
realize the possibility that I mean this
represents a risk for
cross-contamination so it's something
relation for hidden sequencing data and
it is something that you because we're
looking for it in sequencing data you
can see levels that are not detectable
on bioanalyzer or other fragment
analysis traces and so we feel like we
really do go one step beyond what's
typical in proving that our automation
solutions are sound and there the data
you can trust the data that's being
generated so once that review process is
done then you will generate content for
public distribution like this webinar
that you've all kinds of decided to show
up for and then we'll move on to
application installation so we realized
that while we have that you know we have
instrument configurations that we that
we generally suggest 49 in gs
applications that our customers are
working with so much more because our
our liquid handlers really our
application agnostic and there's their
chemistry agnostic and so you might be
doing NGS applications you might be due
to tell you or a protein work and so we
don't force a customer to bias to the
configuration for their instruments so
we recognize that the instruments that
the applications they're what we develop
need to be flexible in their design and
they can be configured properly so
during the course of application
installation our field application
specialist will go through and they will
implement the method on your instrument
and they will form a whole range of
on-site I've heading optimizations off
by 10 things frequently going through a
logistical test to make sure the lab
work is moving properly that your sac
offsets are correct and then they'll
some pipetting testa can actually go
through a complete water run typically
while they're at a customer site so that
you can verify that the pipetting is on
target and then after the application is
installed we have an entire group that
provides tech support for these
applications and other groups that
provide service support for the hardware
and then we have another third group
that provides training and host user
meetings for our customers so the reason
why we do this is we it's not like we're
just going to go through an airdrop in
an application into your site and expect
you to just know how to use it we do
backstop our applications with a very
extensive group of people that do
various varieties to support for our
customers so there's some other
additional software features beyond
biomech software that I wanted to touch
on during the courses presentation both
of which are fairly new biometric
launcher being the newest but these are
software packages that we have developed
because we feel like we can help offer
an improved user experience and better
data management and handling during the
course of the method being rough so you
during the course of the average day
you'll come to your by night and you'll
say I want to run a method alright well
are we sure we picked the right project
and am i working with the most recent
version my method or usually what we
find out in our normal binding method or
methods and finally operators on
vacation and the pio must be to run ass
and I really need some help with this so
for those reasons and several others and
by the way this is what our standard
user interface looks like so if you were
to open up is the editor on your
controller this is what you would see
it's fairly straightforward to use as
far as a programming is concerned the UI
gives you
GUI based interface for building methods
and build and building out software
solutions if you want to if you want to
do that alternatively you can use by an
egg method launcher to launch your
application has been installed already
so if I'm amendment of launcher is a new
product it has two components to it one
is the launcher interface what you're
seeing here and the other one that's
guided lab we're set up those of the
parameter P are the two primary
components here so the launcher nods you
to interact with your instrument without
actually running the editor software so
you would just go in and begin by
magnetic launcher and your applications
would be listed out there on the
launcher and there will be icons alike
just like the right one you can also you
know perform manual control of the
instrument through the launcher as well
just by clicking that on the manual
control tab and it will bring up a whole
variety of options that you can use to
run the instrument once you've selected
your method say for example you want to
run a limit of truce I hate you a virgin
too I think you know based user
interface will pop up and it would give
you the options you need to run the
methods how many samples you want to
process and which components of the
method that you want to run we you know
we build these you live in such a way
that they're easy to operate and should
be fairly straightforward for any
operator to employ the other component
of the final amendment launcher is a new
step up guided lab we're set up so glad
we're set up will step you through on a
plate by plate box by hitbox process to
set the deck up and in such a way that
you know it is properly set up and one
of the things that really does nicely is
that it will go through and we'll show
you side views of stacks of lab where so
you can see that on the right hand side
of your screen and for reagents that are
deployed and troughs or you have master
mixes that you need to create all those
set of instructions are included in the
individual labrum scriptions
additionally you can print off the guide
lever set over the p
and you can take those edit instructions
to back to your bench where you can go
and make up your master mixes the other
thing you can do is you can and the
other thing you can do at those PDS as
the PDS can be uploaded to a lymph
system for example or copied into a lab
notebook to show you know the user
visits what I've done on this particular
day it's a really powerful interface and
I like it quite a lot actually so once
you get beyond guys lab we're set up
then during the courses amended running
this is what the runtime or what the
runtime interface would look like for
binding method launcher so on the Left
you'll see one to beam envy method
screen where it will go through to look
into a progress bar on the top that will
show you how long yeah how long the
method is going to continue so the
dancers the vital question of can i go
and get a cup of coffee or do i have
time to go to the bathroom or is it time
to interact with the instrument and then
it will go through and will offer you a
series of milestones ill let you know
what process it's working on and how
long that individual process is going to
take if you flip over to the method view
over here on the right hand side of your
screen it will actually go through and
show you the five next steps that's
actually looking through and if you go
into the lab where dialogue which is on
the right bottom right of each of those
each of those screens you can actually
click and view the volumes of every
individual piece of lab whereas the
Memphis progressing so you can monitor
its it's running a real time ah yes data
anyway so audition methods can generate
a large number of data that will need to
be tracked just for it and just one well
for example of this one plate we could
attract what the same idea is what the
project idea is what the p.i is we're
working for on this particular project
what species it is the name of the
technician running the a day
concentrations volumes the list goes on
and on and the issue gets exponentially
worse the more plates you process leads
to a lot of data that needs to be
handled
and of course it's not just from you
know this data is piling up during the
course of numerous applications so
you're if you're starting off with NGS
sample side of DNA or RNA you'll want to
know you know where the samples were a
session from any data that's associated
with them including species or the
volume of the concentration or maybe you
have to quantify it in yourself when you
get them in and so one of the things you
can do is you can merge the detector
data and track the data and sample ID to
the dilution plate as you quantify and
normalize the DNA then there's a matter
of doing your NGS library prep and so
that point you want to track what
samples are associated with what in
disease so that you can be multiplex a
sample later and then you want to
exporters some of that data into an
experiment manager for your sample sheet
and then also extend that data to the
lens I lymph system if your lab has one
pronounced your analysis so dark two
point O stands for data acquisition and
reporting tool is if I make data there
is a software package that works with
biometric and SQL to generate a
repository that will track all that
information on a per plate basis so it
can take reader data it will take data
from data sets that are generated as a
part of normal operation for binding
software and it can report them out to
and other devices live system any
web-enabled device a light monitor to
the run in real time or other terminal
inside or outside the lab if you have a
configured right so there's a huge
number of way there's several ways you
can access the data with dart so you can
create a heaven you know the dark
software create lab reports that will
automatically just expel her into saying
cell sheets and then the report contains
an embedded wing to the database so you
can just click refresh on your excel
sheet and then it will automatically
populate that sheet with the
data from the report if you'd ran
another outside for example that's
really convenient you can do is you can
monitor runs in real time using the web
enables they're using the web interface
so dart will report out this method is
running how long it's been running you
can query all the various sorts of lab
where and find out what's been done
because who's been doing the run and you
can use it to generate all kinds of
reports so on the top left we've got the
what the query builder looks like and
you can include any basically if you're
building a report out is just a matter
of clicking which fields you want to
include in the report and so above for
example I've got an illustration where
you're using dart to report data out to
the alumina experiment manager for your
sample sheet generation including the
sample and which I five and I seven
indices have been associated with which
library and on the left on the bottom
there we have you know the library
normalization report from dart to point
out where we're going to work showing
what the starting concentration was how
much volume was moved and what the
normalization concentration was
afterwards so it allows you a variety of
ways of getting access to your data and
storing it so so finally I wanted to
just go over some of our our application
card so we've got website with a link
you can see above info topic and colder
complex NGS and there you'll find our
current NGS library preparation method
card so this meant the card will detail
what methods we've had we've we've
developed what applications we've
developed on which platforms there's
this process this was continually
growing and we're actively adding
content to it on a comp we follow suit
look on a daily basis these days so I
strongly encourage any of any and all of
you to go ahead
zip over to this website and for more
information so finally I just wanted to
invite anyone to send us questions
beauty the Q&A tab and thank you for
attending it's been a pleasure speaking
with you
thank you David and Zach for your
presentations a quick reminder for our
audience on how to submit questions
simply type them in the Q&A box found by
clicking on the green Q&A button at the
lower left of the presentation window
David and Zach will answer as many
questions as time permits first question
is how long does it take to implement an
existing method with no modifications
versus one with modification Oh
everybody this is David so it depends of
the protocol typically we can give an
estimate about two days for a protocol
that would take about a day to process
manually and then extending the length
of implementation for protocols that are
longer than that so if you're looking at
capture protocol that might be a two or
three-day manual protocol then we
typically need about a day to come into
the lab and get the hardware configured
make sure all the checks and balances
are taken care of and then approximately
the time of the manual prep to go
through the protocol on the automation
with water testing and potentially some
portion of a live run to ensure that
everything is working maybe generate
some data with the customer prior to the
application science is leading as far as
custom modifications that all depends on
what the customer is going to need a
compared to our template methods but
typically it will add an extra day for a
shorter protocol or possibly two days
for one of the longer capture protocols
for example to implement those changes
at the customer site ideally those
modifications or changes are addressed
prior to the application scientists
visit so one of those can be dealt with
prior to visit to help speed up the time
when the application scientist is
actually on site you do you have you
ever have testing for a nimble game
capture protocol on the sample prep
machine I don't actually know the answer
that question off the top of my head
if you wouldn't mind emailing that
question to us we can provide you with
the contact information we have your
information now we'll get back to you
and follow up with a response how much
of the work date is needed for 12
samples how much of the work is needed
for as well so is there a particular
application invited that for the nimble
teen protocol the person did not specify
but I believe it is the person that
asked about nimblegen yet so let's just
okay yeah I'm not exactly familiar with
that protocol so we can follow up with
that second part of the question as well
how do I get support for developing
methods not on your list ok so our
methods that are not on our list are can
always be developed a lot of times your
need is is similar in nature to a
protocol that we already have developed
and the modifications from one of the
methods on our list is not that far off
from what your needs are so typically we
work through our field applications team
and you could reach out to your local
sales rep who could put you in contact
with the region specific individual for
handling application development in your
area how often do you add methods to
your menu the the template methods are
developed on an ongoing basis typically
it's the queue is prioritized based on
current feel demand customer demand for
specific applications and currently
we're putting effort into developing
these applications on some of our
smaller platforms so the B 4 k-5 at 4000
and the biomech and acts platforms for
the most part we've been focusing on the
larger higher throughput system the FX
dual pot but you're going to start to
see a lot of these applications rolling
out for the smaller biomech 4000
next platforms what's the pipetting
volume range for your systems we do have
a technical spec document which we can
provide link to if anybody has a
specific request for that I don't know
off the top of my head what the exact
manufacturing specs are although for
most of the NGS methods were pipetting
volume is down to about two microliters
for certain enzymes or adapter transfers
and our systems are more than capable of
handling that volume range with either
RP 20 or 40 50 tips and that that will
work on all syringe sizes so if you're
familiar with our spanning systems we
have 250 micrometer up to 1,000 my
Twitter syringes and those that volume
to microliters is is capable of being
delivered accurately with any of those
syringe sighs raises I'll avenge is a
quick point of clarification on the
nipple gin question from earlier we have
run the nipple jet that fits on our bio
back FXP platform or largest platform
and those were developed in
collaboration with specific customers
and as far as the question about how
long does it take to do 12 samples or
any number of samples that really
depends on the individual method being
run on a specific instrument great so
let's pause for a moment um see if more
questions come in for us to answer and
we will go from there
how much work time is needed for see how
much more time is needed for 12 samples
in library prep using ed auto machine I
guess that we need clarification on the
VV auto auto machines that maybe it was
a second bc by can holder um you know ID
it says using BG i I'm really the person
was not more specific than that I'm
sorry if the hour with the assumption
that statement biomech beckman coulter
biomech automation so 12 sample library
front it really depends on the protocol
so there's protocols that are day long
and are so if we're day long protocol
manually our systems can handle anywhere
typically from one 296 samples and the
automation is capable of processing 96
samples in approximately the same amount
of time is a smaller number of samples
of course with any message you're going
to add time when you increase the sample
number but generally automation is going
to be able to accomplish that much more
effectively than if you were to do it by
hand so if you think through what a
manual protocol would take for
approximately 12 samples it tends to
take approximately the same amount of
time on the automation or faster what
you're gaining there is the efficiency
the reproducibility of being able to
walk away from that process now if you
look at an increased throughput of 96
samples our automated systems can handle
that throughput as well and
approximately the same amount of time
great what we're waiting for additional
questions to come in I would once again
like to thank David Horvath and Zack
Smith for their presentation do you have
any final comments
I'm sorry was that for me yes please if
you have any any closing thoughts you'd
like to share with this please do right
so I just just mentioned that the next
webinar in the series is going to
prepare provide I'm sorry detail like
throughput for some specific method
example so today's webinar is disgusting
more of our overall application
development process things that we
consider when we're developing
applications for a customer and you know
discussing the the data management
capabilities of the dart system and our
new biomech method launcher features so
the next webinar actually the third one
as well are going to focus more on
specific applications so keep a lookout
for those and you'll be able to
hopefully have an application in that
webinar that your laps interested in
there's a lot more specifics about how
we accomplish generating NGS sample prep
with those specific applications thank
you and I'd also like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions we'd also
like to thank our sponsor beckman
coulter life sciences for underwriting
today's educational web cast as a
reminder this webinar is the first and
three parts theory part to DNA and RNA
sequencing sample prep automating simple
to complex methods is available on
demand on the lab roots website please
save the date for part 3 mission
possible automating mgs sample prep for
challenging samples and niche
applications which will be presented on
July 28 registration is now open for
part 3 so feel free to visit the lab
roots website to confirm your attendance
today this webinar has been approved for
continuing educational credits please
click on the CD button at the bottom
left corner and follow the process to
receive your credit this webcast can be
viewed on demand through January 13 to
2017 lab roots will alert you via email
when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that event with
your colleagues you may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye
you